من المعتقد منذ فترة طويلة أن الأشخاص الذين
يعانون من إصابات الدماغ المؤلمة يخرجون
من الغابة بعد علاجهم، وكان هذا
يعتبر أشبه بكسر في الساق
حيث يكون لديك فترة من التعافي ولكن
بمجرد وصولك إلى نقطة معينة، تصبح
الأمور مستقرة ولكن دراسة جديدة  من بين
أكثر من 25
إصابة في الدماغ تصبح حالات مزمنة
تتطلب علاجًا مدى الحياة، فنحن في الواقع
نرى الأشخاص يتغيرون
بعد فترة طويلة من إصابتهم الأصلية، وفي
الواقع الشيء الذي من غير المرجح
أن تفعله هو البقاء على حالك،
ويقول الباحثون إن البعض ما زالوا يعانون من مشاكل في
التفكير في حل المشكلات  أو تنظيم
السلوك وغالبًا ما لا يتم دعمهم بعد
العلاج الأولي مما قد يجعل هذه
المشكلات أسوأ. يعمل المشاركون في الدراسة
على التوصل إلى طرق جديدة لمساعدة
أماكن مثل مرافق الرعاية الصحية
ومراكز العلاج والملاجئ وحتى
السجون على فحص أفضل لأولئك الذين يعانون من
إصابات الدماغ المؤلمة وإعطاء
الرعاية اللازمة إذا أردنا
إدارة
إصابات الدماغ المؤلمة بشكل استباقي مثلما نفعل مع
مرض السكري على سبيل المثال لتحسين
صحة شخص ما وأداء وظائفه
مدى الحياة من أجل الصحة دقيقة أنا آندي
جايثر